when the market gets hot in Silicon
Valley people fragment and start their
own companies a little bit too much and
availability capital capital propels
this so it's more difficult to assemble
and marshal the critical density of
talent I was talking which we were
talking about before with which is what
the maid oh this is doing late what what
made Michael successful was the ability
to do that in Hollywood and what made
him all successful was the ability for
at least a place in time for us to do
that in Palo Alto in Mountain View and
the companies that really succeed become
this magnet for talent and they're able
to sustain it for a significant period
of time but if too many people fragment
it creates almost like an artificially
low number of super successful important
companies yeah so to some extent is
actually easier to be successful when
the macro market cools down a bit
because your ability to get talent in
one place and keep it in one place is
actually improved yeah and so it's um it
would be almost like if it in Hollywood
metaphor if all of a sudden Spielberg
it's like I'm gonna write my own
screenplays and cratons like I'm gonna
start directing it's like well we'd be
better if you guys work together and
kept that talent base together and you
look at the Warriors yes the Warriors
are good sports example of this like
they've actually been able to keep I
went to ice at courtside at the game
just the other day and I was just
watching this game versus a Spurs and I
looked at us like five all-stars are on
the court at the same time Steph clay
drama Kevin Durant and then they put
boogie in there it's just it was just
bizarre to watch they squirt I think 25
baskets in a row or something ridiculous
and you're just watching a gun
god this is such a moment in time yeah
it's very rare especially with you have
this artificial constraint of a salary
cap which doesn't apply as much in the
business world on that's designed to
sort of spread and create more
mediocrity by definition a so salary cap
like is designed to do it can be you can
cheat at the edges and be brilliant at
the edges as the Warriors have been but
in the startup world like you don't have
that artificial constraint you could
actually monopolize talent and that's
one of my goals in life speaking of
Michael Ovitz is I've always joked with
my friends about one day I want to
figure out how to monopolize talent yeah
I haven't quite figured that one out yet
a cap table that can fit everybody got a
salary cap a ball that can be shot by
five people concurrently
it's like there's only one ball yeah
it's very difficult to do I didn't
figure out a scale at two like
generationally like right and people get
older and you want to find up-and-coming
undiscovered talent like you draft
people out of high school and basketball
and how to do that in a scalable way I'd
love to I'll figure out how to put this
all together before I quit this job